Hey, everyone, here a
startling revelation.
Did you know creating
calendar events can
enhance your user's experience
and bring about better
and higher engagement?
This is Wesley Chun, and
by the time I'm done,
you'll be wondering
why you haven't already
implemented this in
your web or mobile apps.
For developers, you'll discover
it's easier than you think.
Your users will save time and
think, yay, what a cool app.
I don't have to do it myself.
To get started,
let's go somewhere
where you can have
such an experience.
Going out with friends to
have a good time is always
a great experience, whether
it's a night at the movies,
going to the game,
or eating out.
Let's say that you've
built a dining reservation
app to simplify
setting up such events.
Besides booking
the reservation, it
notifies guests and handles
RSVPs-- very useful.
But sending email is easy.
How can you make this
experience even better?
All right.
Truth is, while your app
helps users with scheduling,
they're not using your
app for appointments.
They're using a calendar.
Wouldn't it be great if
your app handles the booking
and adds the events
to their calendars?
Users will love your
app because they
don't have to manually add
those events to their calendars.
Time and effort
saved for the win.
And that's how you take a good
experience and make it great.
Today's calendar--
people rely on it
to organize their lives,
at work and at home.
When booking events using
your app, whether it's
a dining reservation,
plane ticket, hotel
room, a night at the
game, or a concert,
it's an extra chore for people
to get it into their calendars.
So how do you automate
calendar events then?
With the Google Calendar API.
It sounds complicated,
but really, it's
easier than you think.
To help you get started, let's
look at a short Python script
that creates an event with a
minimal amount of information
and code.
At the end, I'll have a link
to the docs where you can see
similar examples in Java,
.NET, PHP, and more,
including mobile environments
like Android and iOS.
Ready?
Let's go to the computer now.
OK, let's start at the top.
We need to import the
print_function for Python 2
users since it's
the default in 3.X.
The goal is to have code that
runs in both Python 2 and 3.
The Google Calendar API is
another authorized Google API,
so the remaining imports
are the same to access
any authorized API,
just like we've
seen in previous episodes.
What does change,
however, are the scopes.
We're now using Calendar,
thus need one of its scopes.
Currently, the Calendar
API has a read-only
and a read/write scope.
Since we're adding a
new Calendar event,
we need read/write, which
is this particular scope.
The rest of the boilerplate
remains the same.
Completing the OAuth
process, where if successful,
ends with granting
this script the ability
to access the calendar
data of the user who
gave the authorization.
With permissions granted, we can
now create a service endpoint
to the Calendar API.
Use calendar as the API
name, v3 as the current API
version-- at least it was
when we recorded this video.
Finally, pass in the
HTTP connection objects
so requests are signed
with your credentials.
In order to create
an event, we need
to call the API with the
necessary event details,
so that's next.
The GMT_OFF variable is for
my local time zone, which
is Pacific daylight time,
or a mountain standard time,
which is GMT minus seven hours,
but you should use your own.
The data in the EVENT variable
is the bare minimum, an event
name plus start and end times.
Now that we've got
the data that we need,
it's time to call the API
with the service endpoint
CAL that we got earlier.
We'll use the event
object's insert method.
The calendarId is the
ID of the calendar
to insert the event into.
The special name primary
refers to the currently
authorized user so that's
what you'll typically use.
sendNotifications
is the flag that
says send an email notification
of the new calendar event.
If you're inviting friends, it's
probably nice to let them know.
Finally, pass in the
event details as the body
and execute the API call.
Now, this will work,
but how can you
tell the event was
successfully added?
Well, you can't unless you
check the return value, which
is this variable e up here.
It's the event object that
serves as a receipt containing
the event details, which are
then displayed to the screen
using the print call
down at the bottom.
All right, now we're
ready to save and run it.
And as you can see, we get
the familiar OAuth prompt.
So this is the
actual action that
lets the user authorize that
script access to their calendar
data.
So we're going to allow.
And you can see here that the
print function has completed,
which means there should
be a dinner with friends
on our calendar.
And there it is.
That's great.
Whoops, we forgot to
invite our friends.
If you look at the event,
there's no friends in here.
So unfortunately, we've got
to delete it and do it again.
So how do we add friends?
Well, you go back into the code
and, particularly the event
data, and add a
list of attendees,
just giving them the email
addresses for all your friends.
All right, now if we
save and run it again,
we'll get more success
OK, it looks like the
event has been added again.
And this time,
your friend should
have gotten an
email notification,
besides the calendar
event, which you can see
here along with some friends.
It even works for non-Google
users, such as my friend here
who has an AOL account.
If you click through, you'll
see the user interface isn't as
rich, but they can still RSVP.
So that's it.
Cool.
You've programmatically created
your first Google Calendar
event.
Wow, that's it, all in
less than 40 lines of code.
As you can see, it doesn't take
much to add a calendar event,
meaning it doesn't
take much effort
to give your users a seamless
and delightful experience.
Inserting events is
just the beginning.
Think of the API as a
way to really open up
the power of Google Calendar
and integrating its features
into your app.
It will be able to update and
delete events, not just add.
If your events have
location information,
users can get Google Now cards
that tie in with Google Maps,
providing time and
proximity info.
Adding events that repeat, like
monthly dinners and book club
meetings, is a cool thing.
Attachments are supported so you
can add event-related documents
like a PDF of the show tickets.
Where do you go now?
Well, the first link gets you
started with the official docs.
Want to enhance the email
you're already sending to users?
Well, check out the
episode at link number two.
Finally, down at the
bottom, are links
to connect you to more episodes
in this and other Google
Developer video series.
By intelligently
and more completely
managing your users'
overall experience,
you simplify their lives by
saving them time and effort,
and they can rest assured they
won't miss the event, leading
to a high rate of engagement.
In turn, they will thank you
by continuing to use your app
rather than the competition's.
Leverage the power of
the Google Calendar API
and see how it can take
your app to the next level.
I'm Wesley Chun from
Google and we'll
see you the next time
on the LaunchPad Online.
[MUSIC PLAYING]